praying to god every day show me the
truth i am ready to see the truth no
matter
which religion it is i want to go down
that path
and ever since you guys posted that
first podcast i have been like
yeah no this is it like everything you
say just makes sense the more
the more you say about it it's like yeah
yeah there's no contradictions about it
there's no one in my mind gone no this
is this don't make sense to me
everything is like
yes this is this is almost perfect this
is
it if there is a religion out there
that is the truth it would have to be
[Music]
islam
[Music]
guys and girls welcome back to t3m it's
yours fired
with rami uh doman ano not being home he
had some prior
uh arrangements so he will be on next
time inshallah we got kevin from
ireland how you doing kevin all good man
how are you stan
yeah we're solid so uh kevin actually
reached out to us he's been you've been
watching on health for a couple years
right
and then you found a podcast and tell me
man tell me a little bit about your
journey
how you were in terms of religion where
you were and
what kind of brought you to want to
revert to a song
all right so i grew up as
like i was born into becoming a catholic
so to space that's what my parents
believed in and
my dad's a strong believer in that my
mom is just a bit like
she doesn't believe at all but she kind
of believes in a god
and so i kind of just grew up believing
and that sort of stuff
and there yeah as i got older it just
i kind of just faded away from it like
my parents they they weren't
they weren't strict on it they just kind
of like yeah you can have your own
beliefs
whatever and um i just started to kind
of
fade away from believing in a god and
i didn't really look into it too much
either i kind of just thought like
oh that just sounds so unrealistic um
didn't make sense to me and
yeah so i just kind of stopped believing
and
kind of new age stuff you know yourself
with that
like tear dye and all that
i kind of start looking into that a bit
um
and in a way you kind of brought a sense
of inner peace
but it's it's um it's hard to explain it
just
it won't bring you that that fullness
like feeling whole like grounded
it won't do that to you it's kind of
like short-term gratification in a way
builds your ego and but it's not good in
the long run i don't feel like anyways
it wasn't good for me
that sort of stuff just kind of brought
more anxieties
than anything else and
so yeah i faded away from that again and
i just kind of
lost touch with religious side of
spiritual side
just kind of like to look at someone who
was religious
and to see that would kind of be like
i'll kind of be like
uh they're just a bit weird like you
know it just
didn't make sense to me so
oh it was going through a roof at like
a rough stage in my life like this was
going over it was spanning over
i'd say a whole year and i just
i just started praying again because i
was like why not
and what's the worst that can happen so
i was like i'll just reach out
reach out see what happens like what
else what what do i've got to do so
every night
before i'd sleep i just kind of pray to
god whatever i thought
god was at that stage i just kind of
prayed to him
and yeah
just asking him for a better life a bit
better everything really and then kind
of
yeah i didn't really know what i was
doing so
anyways a few weeks later this was this
was like a year on from
like this really bad period in my life
like this probably the worst period
of my life that i've had um
so yeah i was watching a youtube video
and this guy just started talking about
god
and this is what this is like a small
youtuber like this guy that i watched he
just started talking about god i don't
know why
he um he was talking about basically
everything about submitting to god and
letting just kind of giving yourself
over to the creator like and what i
didn't realize what i was doing was i
was trying to control my life everything
around me
i was putting all the pressure on myself
and everything he said just kind of
spoke with me
and it was this weird experience like
almost similar to anger and girls
i'm not saying his name right but and
his
his experience the way he kind of
the way he kind of had these feelings
come to him and i can kind of relate to
him
a little bit because when this guy was
speaking in his video
it almost felt like a whole weight was
lifted off my shoulders
and i felt this like
presence would you say just just this
like like everything was going to be
okay
and i did not have an ounce of doubt in
that
i just knew like everything was going to
be okay
and i i believed and i got 100
after after that experience like it just
kind of clicked to me i don't know what
it was
but um yeah i didn't know anything about
god or any religions
even catholic christianity islam
anything like that i did not know
anything about any of them
and i just kind of was like okay god has
to be real i just i've
felt something here so ever since then
i've been kind of
been seeing little signs and little
little almost similarities like that
and it's just like just back in that
look it wasn't like a once-off thing
um so yeah i just started believing in
that
you know jesus again because because
that's what that's all i knew
that's what i grew up to believe and i
was like okay yeah
i bought a cross necklace i was like all
right this is
i believe i am and i got in the car
the dell bought that cross necklace
uh a song popped up and it was like
uh the first words that came onto the
song
from the radio my dad turned on the
radio and i had this necklace on the
first thing
i swear the song said that
it was like oh you're gonna go to heaven
or something like that
i'm a bad singer i'm not gonna try
recreate it but
it said you're gonna go to heaven and
that was like
another like back up to that sort of
sort of story anyways that sort of thing
like that
of my belief and
yeah so i was like wow this is kind of
crazy
like this is kind of afraid i need to
look more into this i just can't
i can't just sit and then
expect to have all these great things
happen to me like i kind of felt this
need to
go out there and then look more into it
and kind of
i don't know i feel like i kind of need
to show how grateful i am to that if
that makes sense you know
[Music]
100 of them and and i was going to ask
you like what brought you specifically
to islam
when did you know i know because you you
came to me and you had some
inquiries you were like okay i i feel
good about islam
i have some type of concern with the
free will thing and we talked about it
here and there you know this concern
that concern but
when did you realize that 100 islam was
the answer
yeah so um i was praying and looking
more into it
and just this whole christianity
catholic all that
all that sort of side all the other
religions because like i
delved deep into them all i was looking
into them all because i wanted to know
the truth
i was praying to god every day showing
me the truth i am ready to
see the truth no matter which religion
it is i want to go down that path
um so yeah i start praying to him every
day
every night and
just trying to look for any signs i
could see um
and i was looking more into the religion
i grew up with and it just did not make
sense to me whatsoever
it didn't click with me you know like uh
the more you look into it it didn't
click so
so then this is what kind of brought me
to islam i was watching
as you know i know anger i've known him
since
three four years i just used to watch
his youtube videos
and i'd look up to this guy you know he
helped me his tips
they helped me a lot and i respect his
word and
he post he posted a video of him
reverting to
becoming a muslim and i was like oh this
is kind of crazy i might just i might
just look into it
and and ever since
you guys posted that first podcast i
have been like
yeah no this is it like everything you
say just makes sense
the more the more you say about it it's
like yeah yeah there's no contradictions
about it
there's nothing in my mind gone no this
is this don't make sense to me
everything is like yes this
is this is almost perfect this is it
this this has to be the truth
if there is a religion out there that is
the truth
it would have to be islam and
and yeah i look more into it a lot of
water channels
um and just everything that i've been
learning about it it just
it it seems like the right way and i
definitely do believe
that god the only way he could have
reached me to become close with him
was true jesus at that time
because if so if god if if i had
received like a sign to
go straight to islam i would have been
like now what's
what's this this does not make no sense
whatsoever
you know but because i grew up with um
with like jesus the church is all around
me
they kind of see all them songs to have
it relate to me a little bit
it was like okay yeah i want to get
closer to god now
and now i now i'm ready to go to the
truth
and that's not close to
that's proper man what i will say uh to
any of you guys
that are the viewers today at home we
will insha allah
without a doubt have kevin back on
another podcast
to tell us his story after
reverting what happened his kind of
journey what he did
because again you're new into this right
it's not really fair asking you about
what's your journey
after becoming a muslim because you
haven't even done your shahada yet but
after you become a muslim how was it to
learn how to pray it's easy but we want
to know your take on it
you know kind of the changes you had to
make so we will have a whole full length
episode inshallah and we would love to
have you on that
um but uh again for now we got like five
minutes left on the clock
so i say we just go in with the shahada
and
yeah man i had a few when you were ready
when you reached out to me for a
meal plan for those of you that know
don't know kevin is one of those like
few that's a client of mine
because i do online coaching and he
reached out and he was like okay give me
a meal plan
just no pork and i was like okay that's
that's kind of interesting
but again it's it's almost like we
become muslim before we become muslim
so masha'allah with that i know your
fitra your soul
has already accepted it you kind of work
towards your ego just accepting it now
uh so yeah i say we just seal the deal
and legitimize it right now
so in terms of the actual shahadah rami
do you want to tell him the english
transliteration first
or translation first english translation
first
yeah let's let's go over that okay yeah
so bismuth
praises to allah the most merciful
especially merciful
who guided you who guided me who god is
fired and all the muslims alhamdulillah
so firstly when we say the testimony
we're testifying
this is the translation there is no god
worthy of worship
except allah all right so anything you
could take as a
to worship none of it is worthy of
worship except god
allah alone and the prophet muhammad
peace be upon him is his last and final
messenger
that's the shahadah that is the first
thing you need to
believe in and say in to actually be
a full muslim so with that being said
my dear brother kevin are you ready to
say the shahadah
yeah all right so first
we're going to repeat after me in arabic
and then we're going to say in english
okay
we're going to go slow okay
[Music]
and now you're going to repeat after me
in english i bear witness
i bear witness that there is no god
worthy of worship
that there is no god worthy of worship
except allah
accept allah and i bear witness
and i bear witness that the prophet
muhammad
that the prophet muhammad is his last
and final
messenger is his last and final
messenger allah congratulations habibi
kevin you are now a muslim
congratulations on accepting the truth
nothing makes me more happy with allah
uh what's the first thing that comes to
mind right now
i'm just grateful i've stumbled across
the truth right now
and you know i'm grateful that i've
been put on this part to kind of
you know better myself better my life
and
you know i'm really appreciative of
appreciative of you both as well doing
this for me
i'm just grateful man i'm just happy you
know 100
man and again we will definitely get in
touch with you um
you know in the very near future
sometime in the next few days
just to give you kind of the next steps
because again as a new reaver it might
be kind of confusing what to do what to
not do
but in terms of your testimony in terms
of your conviction
i'm glad that 100 you resonate with the
truth
and for any of you guys watching uh
you know please make dua for kevin that
you know he stays steadfast on the path
to becoming a better muslim and to
become a practicing muslim
and to keep him away from shaitaan and
just any type of evil
and harm's way
one final word if i may add um you said
you are grateful to us habibi we are
grateful you know to you for coming on
and being you know
accepting of the truth and we're all
grateful to allah
because me and fayyad were in your
position perhaps even worse at a point
in time
and it's really funny that you look at
us now and you say you're grateful to us
when in reality all three of us are
grateful to the same source
alhamdulillah
and nobody really stumbles upon the
truth as if it's an accident
we only become guided and alhamdulillah
each of us were you know humbled and
sincere enough to actually accept it
and we were not from the people who were
arrogant and brush it aside so
alhamdulillah all thanks to allah
who guided us
brave enough to do this on camera um so
man it blows my mind masha'allah think
about how you're gonna inspire now
just because someone's saying that
shahadah is so inspiring to people
and actually inspires more people to say
the shahadah so may allah make it you
know
an act of of worship and a good deed
from yourself habibi kevin
amongst the first good deeds that you
know you do while being a muslim masha
allah
i mean and guys if if all of you guys
don't want to you know
you don't have to come and do it with us
uh you don't have to have us record it
you don't have to do any of that if you
want us to not record it
cool hit us up if you would even not
want to even join us and you want to do
it just
in your bed you're allowed to do it
anywhere provided you have full
conviction and full testimony and full
trust in what you are saying and you're
believing in we will put in the
description box
below so feel free to head there and
do the do when you're ready but in terms
of that kevin do you have any last words
um no
um
he's ready all right guys so uh with
that being said
remember guys uh life is short so
rami hand it out for us may allah bless
you all thank you all for joining us
thank you again brother kevin happy be
our new
brother in islam may allah bless him may
love bless all of you and increase you
all aloha
for donating
and alhamdulillah to kevin for being
ireland's latest
muslim masha allah
[Music]
um